sur ces arbres la doyenne et du comice
juteuse et sucrée
cette reine des poires est en avance la
production a démarré il ya dix jours
elle est plutôt bonne cette année mais
il faut choyer ce bijou séduit autant un
peu exceptionnel qu'on a eu cette année
avec des périodes très chaude avec une
floraison qui a démarré assez tôt des
conditions qui auraient donc été très
très bonne ça a été très vite et ça en
général quand on prend de l'avancé en
début de saison en fin de saison c'est
normal qu'on cueille plus tôt il faut
absolument poser les fruits ne pas les
lâcher ou non du vidage ce que va faire
vidal maintenant mon du village dans le
box vraiment vidé tout doucement de
façon à ce que des frings aux chocs
frontières une dizaine de salariés
travaillent depuis dix jours dans ce
verger de 12 hectares durant encore
trois semaines ils payeront en tout 350
tonnes de poires à l'image de bilal
c'est sa première cueillette mais il a
le coup de main il faut observer s'il
n'y a pas si elle n'est pas habile mais
il faut laisser la queue et puis il faut
prendre une grande taille si lé petit
ange et s'il a par exemple ici et elle a
de deux petits trous ça n'a pas pour
l'âge est si la production est bonne
c'est parce que les arbres ont pu être
protégées contre le gel en avril dernier
un épisode de dix jours assez violent
les arrange sans protection ont souffert
exemple un peu plus loin avec les
pommiers surtout le bas de l'arbre plus
de fruits on commence à avoir des frères
peu près à cette hauteur là la voyez on
peut avoir une perte à son endroit là
qui est quand même assez importante
heureusement ma cg l'insensé l'essentiel
de mon verger est protégé mais revenons
à ces fruits pas encore mûrs ils vont
être stockés pendant près de trois
semaines avant d'être vendus il faudra
un peu de patience avant de déguster ses
rennes en robe verte
ce verger ouvrira ses portes la semaine
prochaine pour permettre aux clients de
cueillir eux-mêmes les fruits